عندما حصلت على المعلومات الأولى التي تفيد بأن
برشلونة يريد التوقيع معي ، كان
هذا النوع من
التفكير في ذهني
ممتعًا للغاية وكنت سعيدًا
بهذا بالتأكيد أنني يجب أن أفكر في هذا
لأنه بعد ثماني سنوات في بايرن
ميونيخ  أنني فزت بكل شيء وأكون
ممتنًا أيضًا لأه
لزملائي في الفريق في ميونيخ ، لكنني أردت أن
أفعل ذلك خطوتي التالية في مسيرتي لأفعل
ذلك في الفصل التالي وعندما تحدثت
مع مدير الرياضة مع ماتيو
الرئيس أعلم أنهم يريدونني
كثيرًا ويفعلون كل شيء لإحضارتي إلى
برشلونة وبالنسبة لي كانت هذه علامة
أيضًا حسنًا ، أنا مستعد للانتقال أنا مستعد
للاستمتاع ببرشلونة لأن هذا
المشروع هو المستقبل حتى هذا
كانت أشهر العام الماضي صعبة للغاية على هذا
النادي الآن ، وأرى أن هذا هو المستقبل الذي
يتحسن ويسير بسرعة كبيرة
لأكون في القمة وهذا هو السبب
في أنني أفعل ذلك ، ولم أفكر
في الانتقال إلى بارتون أيضًا  منذ فترة طويلة لأنني
أعرف أن هذا هو الوقت المناسب f  أو
أنا وللنادي أيضًا